we're going to talk about call of duty 4
modern warfare remastered which is
included with a few different bundles
for call duty infinite warfare and you
guys had a chance to play it recently I
don't play a lot of Call of Duty as much
as I love the campaigns I actually
really wasn't into it back then how does
it feel to revisit this game after what
is it six years seven nine nine years
yeah yes honey its I was joking about
this with John Luke yesterday there that
we've had a couple of remasters come out
a year ahead of their ten-year
anniversary when it wouldn't end it
would I don't know if it would make more
sense but it would feel more like a
culmination right but Bioshock was the
same way that came out nine years
instead of ten years whatever yeah you
know playing playing them on stream
yesterday was it's crazy
every mission is like oh my god this
mission this mission is so great every
time we got something news okay oh this
thing happens yeah this is so good so it
sticks with you even after all those
years for a serious not a lot of games -
yeah well I mean a ton of games but I
mean really that first modern warfare
was it set the template for basically
everything that's happened in Call of
Duty since then with the exception of
like maybe the black ops games just
really kind of found their own voice and
did their own thing but at least in
terms of the modern warfare trilogy and
even the games that have happened since
then like ghosts and I would assume to
some extent infinite warfare everything
everything about those games was really
established right away in in modern
warfare so it's crazy to go back and
play it and see just how fully realized
that whole vision was just right out of
the gate how much of like the pacing and
the set pace driven ness of it like all
these different ideas were there from
the very beginning it's it's so cool
what about Rob for you like mechanically
does this game still feel like up to par
with what we've had you know since I was
you know I only played like a good hour
and a half and I was kind of going back
and forth personally I just wanted to
get to that all gilead up mission the
sniping ones I remember like having such
great memories of that but you totally
hit the nail on the head of like there
was one the mission I played was where
there's an Abrams tank that's like
stranded in the middle of an area yeah
you know talking about it we'd have to
basically go rescue rescue it and man it
was the weirdest flashback of like
hugging a corner and not even getting to
that open area for you know lucky to be
there I remember
having played that like so many times
like just that was burned in my head was
how hard it was I must have played on
different difficulty because I kind of
flew right yeah that was really kind of
cool I remember just like out loud
saying like oh I remember this like I'm
hugging the corner like same thing I'm
Shane stop dude we got we got the one
part in the mission yesterday and we as
we were running a quarter we're both
like wait a min I know it's about to
happen and then sure enough we turned
the corner and there's this TV station
which we both remembered as having
infinitely spawning enemies and being
just impossible to get through and even
in shadow runs like oh yeah that
building sucks we hid as far the game
but like before we actually got there
we're like wait this seems familiar
there it is I was
yeah just like so many of those moments
it's great but as far as and again like
touching back when I was trying to say
it was like fighting whether or not I
would play this like it felt like I was
playing it more for nostalgia sake okay
like trying to imagine how impactful
this game truly was at that time however
I was not it felt very Arkady right like
it was very much like the animations of
ai ai in general was pretty poor they're
just standing there shooting at you and
you know there's the sometimes I like to
imagine you know called you D game to
overtime have got more realistic to an
extent yeah this just felt again very
Arkady I felt like I was standing up you
know with like a plastic toy like
shooting at guys like in waves and like
the structure of certain areas was like
okay now it's this type of layout now
they're gonna come in waves or it just
kind of felt like I was fighting myself
on whether I was actually enjoying it or
whether I was like playing a memory um
but I will say that visually it's pretty
up to par like you know textures are
revamped it looks it looks pretty good
I'd say there's like a lack of shadows
here and there where it's like very
obvious connections of you know polygons
you're like just wall I was like okay
like that looks a little weird but in
general I know it's fun it was fun to
see like Captain Price again yeah and
here like him bark around a team and go
through houses and stuff there were a
lot of cool moments that I yeah you just
it again yeah I just feel like it's just
a nostalgia thing or it's like oh that's
cool
member this okay so on that point then
right so this is part of a series of
bundles that you can buy infinite
warfare so how does that sit with you
guys is that like maybe a good way to
entice people that love a series too to
continue loving it and maybe pay a
little bit more money you know just for
a dressed-up version of an old game or
is this kind of just an afterthought
that you guys were happy to play with
but you might not go back to I would
necessarily call it an afterthought I I
feel like they did a good job with 3-4
you like isn't afterthought for you at
this point you played it a little bit
and now you've got infinite warfare
coming right do you feel like you know
you've enjoyed this somewhat it sounds
like do you want to keep playing it or
are you kind of satisfied to get that
just that taste I mean I actually might
go back and beat it me the campaign's
not super long it's like what eight
eight hours maybe like you can actually
beat it in you know one really good
sitting or if you want if you really
want to grind through on veteran it'll
take you a little longer but honest you
just put it on normal let it kind of
sweep you up I mean I think rob was very
right that it isn't the most challenging
game in a lot of ways the AI is pretty
predictable most of the scenarios are
kind of like easy to read but really
what makes it fun is you just kind of
get swept up in the chaos of all of it I
mean remember at the time it was really
unusual to have so much happening around
you in any given mission right I mean
every mission you were immersed in some
larger battle of which you were only one
small part and that you know this is
cinematics and like everything about it
that made it feel so immersive that was
what was cool about it so yeah I mean
they've never been the most challenging
games but they're really easy to get
swept up in so I personally would
probably go back and play a little more
and and beat the campaign especially
since it's you know relatively short and
I mean I remember really enjoying the
multiplayer at the time as well so that
I might not stick with quite as long it
depends I mean I'd have to jump in and
play it off fortunately I haven't had a
chance to play the remastered
multiplayer yet so hard to say but I
don't know and and I think that the
audience that cares about Modern Warfare
remaster isn't necessarily the audience
that cares about infinite warfare I
think that a lot of that goodwill has
kind of burned away over the years and
call duty absolutely has it's kind of
core audience that buys the game every
every single year but sort of the the
the longtime fans or people who've been
playing in for a really long time a lot
of those people tend to be kind of down
on call of duty because it's an
annualised release and they might care
more about the nostalgia of replaying
that first really truly great
game versus you know playing the next
iteration of this franchise it's now
been running for such a long time and
it's had has seen at least one release I
think every single year for the almost a
decade but their only option now is to
buy infinite warfare in order to access
which is the unfortunate rub for a lot
of people I think yeah in terms can you
remind me what the package there are are
three different ones let me see here
we've got there's like a deluxe edition
the legacy okay legacy digital deluxe
our legacy Pro Edition of infinite
warfare yeah and you have these
pre-purchase not just pre-ordered oh
really you have to give Activision
actual money Wow and then you will be
able to play the game and that's
starting tomorrow you will be able to
download modern warfare although you can
also like wait and buy infinite worker
on disc and then use the disc but the
disc has to remain in the system play a
modern warfare so you can't just like
buy the game download modern warfare and
you know sell your copy if it were fair
to gamestop or anything like that do you
think you would be just as enjoyable
just to go back and play the original
release of this game or does it doesn't
need the new sort of gussied up in HD
visuals that's a good question
I mean this is something we've talked
about on about several remasters that I
sort of feel like our memories of how
games looked aren't necessarily accurate
I think we remember things look better
than they actually did and playing again
on the stream yesterday it looks it
looks very good it looks like a game
that could have come out two three years
ago as supposed to nine years ago
sure and it on a different console
generation so I think this this is kind
of the way to play especially now that
I've sat down and played a couple hours
I don't know that I could ever go back
to the original I mean I think we're
probably so working on a side-by-side
visual comparison so that'll give us a
little more to work from but yeah I
would I would recommend that you know if
you really really want to play the the
campaign again probably worth playing
the remaster if you can I think I'd be
the better version that's a super good
question cuz like what I was getting the
most out of it was that nostalgia trip
hmm it's like why not just play the
original game hmm
exactly right yeah I mean it does look
pretty good again it's like you're just
fighting like for me I was just kind of
fighting my opinion it looks like oh I
guess this
hi-rez explosion looks kind of good well
that's that kind of looks good it looks
good I don't know I was going back and
forth but I was enjoying that trip it
was cool all right remember in that game
yeah yeah
all right well those are our impressions
of call duty 4 modern warfare
remastered which you can get if you buy
one of the deluxe editions of the
upcoming infinite warfare that's a lot
of duties and infinite warfare if you're
interested in this game let us know in
the comments below and do you think that
remasters are a good source of revenue
or your time down the road